i'm am i going like crazy or is like the
internet gotten like the worst in like
the past five years am i crazy i don't
think you're crazy at all i feel like
it's gotten significantly worse
no no no the whole internet but the way
as in like the level of like
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah yeah maybe that was
messed uh there was a lot of messed up
stuff like you know five six years ago
whatever but like i feel like now it's
all just out there i feel like it's just
so it's so interesting how it's like
almost like an opposite effect that's
happening like for somehow for some
reason
even though the internet or the internet
culture and people on the internet in
the past five six years have gotten more
pc than ever before
and yet
like almost counter-intuitively there's
more [ __ ] up [ __ ] that has like come
out onto the surface as well i think
that's what like retaliation maybe i
don't know
yeah you see the more that these people
because like like i've seen i i see [ __ ]
now on like regular twitter and
instagram that you know you'd only have
a final like the [ __ ] b board yeah
it's weird man because you're just like
i'm
am i weird for for being like middle
ground on everything like i feel like i
have very normal opinions on this yeah
but the more i'm online i'm like am i am
i
not normal do i have not normal opinions
yeah like what is a normal opinion yeah
yeah just like
just being i feel like being fair yeah
i'm like i don't really have heavy
opinions on well i see other people i'm
like oh my god yeah yeah i mean common
sense has definitely become less common
that's for sure no it's weird
i don't know what's common sense anymore
yeah it's
it does feel like is is this the point
where you know the
where the older generation starts
talking about [ __ ] talking the new
generation you know what i mean like
these damn kids yeah because
did you ever think like this is i i
think it's the opposite i i think it's
because the internet in general has
become more accessible to every age
group they were seeing all of this
before it was just it was just like 20
year olds who who gave enough [ __ ] to go
on yeah
yeah and i felt that it was a very
exciting time and everyone was like
really into it and you know and then
your website's probably the new hip
thing yeah mini clip was still thriving
you know uh
farmville was still going strong um
mafia city uh i'm just gonna keep naming
him good old days
i feel like now because it's become so
normalized and everyone uses it
like do you remember do you remember a
point where it felt like there was a
separation between what you did on the
internet and what happened in real life
oh absolutely and i feel like when that
barrier kind of like kind of like got
broken where you felt like what happened
in the internet was like was pertaining
to like your active your your at your
how can i say this
because like internet is real life but
it didn't feel so like
suffocating yeah you know it didn't feel
like it didn't feel like it had a yeah
had a tangible effect on your you know
on your day-to-day life but now it feels
like whatever's going on in the internet
whatever's going on in the world has
this tangible effect this tangible
uh
the tangible effect on what's going on
in you know what you're doing you
literally just explained the plot to
serial experiments lane mm-hmm like
what's the time you think it is i'm
curious if you have the same opinion on
this what you said the time when it felt
like that became
the time when it felt like i became like
i feel it depends on how long you've
been on the internet right like yeah did
you ever do like myspace uh no i came
right after my did you do myself did you
have a bibo
i had bb i did that was very popular in
the yeah okay yeah would you would you
say like so like the bibo and myspace
here right like roughly the same time i
would say yeah right like when you were
on bibo and when people on myspace were
on myspace did you see that as like this
is
me like completely tangible
social media is a game right yeah it's
it's it's like how i go into sims and i
make myself look attractive i think yeah
because like that's how i kind of traded
myspace as well at the time right it's
just it's just yeah it's like it's like
a social zone right yeah yeah yeah it's
it's like i i think i think what really
uh the the first time i really thought
of social media as
a game was actually uh
so charlie brooker do you know charlie
brooker he wrote black mirror yeah so
like a few years ago or maybe even a
decade ago i can't remember how old this
video is he did like a top 50 most
influential games of like all time
and uh like number one was twitter like
like and and i was just like what are
you talking about charlie brooker
because before that he talked about you
know games like that's not a game last
of us [ __ ] tetris you know all these
games and now and he was just like well
think about it you play as an avatar on
an online platform where you gain points
for interacting with the game and i'm
just like
yeah i mean he's kind he's very right
he's like social media at this point is
a game and we are all like the game now
is our job you know it it is our job
because we're falling right into the
system we are we are part of the system
guys
we can't criticize the system because we
are the system we are the system we are
part of the system but that is
definitely how
social media has become and i mean like
in a way like i see especially like
youtube and stuff as like a kind of like
a game i mean it's been it's been
gamified to [ __ ] you post a video
you post a video and it even puts you on
a leaderboard on like how well he's
performed in like the thought in the
past 10 vid uploads you've done but but
the game
the the stakes to it or whatever you
give it yeah like a game is it's the
same with anything right like it you
know [ __ ] jump king whatever whatever
it is it's the game zero days the game
only means whatever you you assigned to
it yeah right so if you with the videos
right if you're making these videos for
the purpose of of cracking that one out
of ten then yeah if you're making the
video because you wanna make a video and
i think when though it's a game yeah
like when you get to that point it's
like you're kind of testing the limits
on what you can call a game right like
you know is the stock market a game
yeah
some people will say yeah some people
say yes some people say no
it's it's it's roulette with extra steps
it's really it's all out with massive
repercussions
let's rule out where there's a really
really boring option that will probably
pay you back or you can spin the wheel
yeah spin the wheels
[Laughter]
it's like deal on no deal but it's
actually serious yeah i felt like the i
don't know when the internet started to
become very very real if you will yeah
uh but it definitely jacked up to 100 at
2016. i think that was when it
definitely like
2016.
election huh first presidential uh
trump's president
i feel like that's when it just went
boom
that's when like the two the split went
like crazy i felt like the the
left-leaning internet right-wing
internet just went
really full-on i feel like i think it
might fall i think it might be earlier
and it's just that we weren't really
aware of it you know you know you know
when it was
i'm saying i've started then but that's
when that's when the dial went like
[ __ ] 500. yeah you know what it was
what there's one youtube rewind started
becoming [ __ ]
i'm just thinking back and i'm just
thinking yeah when you choose one as in
when everything on the internet stopped
being universally loved yeah yeah yeah
basically when we started like being
segmented i guess i i just like i'm just
going i just tried to verbalize how i
felt and i'm just like kind of feels
around the same time that i stopped
giving a [ __ ] about youtube rewind yeah
so that kind of feels like it was 2014
2013 maybe something like that very like
very early on when i stopped when the
when the internet stopped being like one
conglomeration and just beca and you see
things happening and you just didn't
recognize who this person was who that
person was people stopped getting along
uh and you know factions and groups
started to form and uh yeah but that's
why i took something like the the
presidential election which is like the
most
uh televised
horse race in existence yeah it's like
it's so
you know other countries we don't you
know the uk it's like yeah we have this
whole thing about who the new prime
minister is going to be but yeah we
don't nearly like make it as exciting
you know as america does america's so
good at me
i feel like it was the perfect event
that was so polarizing and so well
telegraphed with so much information and
so many parties putting stuff into it i
think regardless of your opinion on it
yeah and who you voted for i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm just saying you can't ignore
the fact that this was a thing that just
really took the internet and just
[ __ ] right i think it's also around
the time roughly when like a lot of
social media sites were like just where
that kind of discussion was just
becoming more open like that was roughly
around the time where like twitter
increased their like character limit
yeah people were like so people you know
could only tweet about like yay obama
one and that was it and now it was like
let me write a full [ __ ] novel about
how i feel about this presidential
election and then you know this is when
they also
after that is when the platform started
having to
correct misinformation yeah and that
further caused more of a device yeah and
then now there's just different
different platforms for different
opposing views so now you don't even get
you don't even get to hear the other
side
yeah i feel like what was so prevalent
about just not just the presidential
election but just that year in general
was that it felt like that was the real
turning point for
where social media kind of felt just
like a tv show it was like a part of
entertainment right where the the the
presidential uh election is the most is
the best rated tv show of all time i'd
probably say yeah yeah everybody i'm
tunes in the watch the next episode yeah
i mean like i mean it even had like a
build up season uh which was uh brexit
right yeah yeah
we had like the mid season was that the
pilot effort that was the mid season
twist right we had the mid season twist
and we were like guys
this show can't get any better there's
no possible way they can surprise me
jokes on you you'll never expect what
comes next
just just [ __ ] look right look at the
how they decide the nominee for the
presidential thing look at that [ __ ]
it's laid out like who wants to be a
millionaire
they're in the semi-circle with all this
amazing [ __ ] tv show s britain's got
talent background and they all take
turns a massive audience and [ __ ] what
is this [ __ ] yeah like what
who gives a [ __ ] let the party pick and
then we'll [ __ ] decide who wins
this whole thing is so
reality tv show-esque yeah it's so
bizarre like when you sit down and
you're like what am i watching like this
is this is [ __ ] up